and finally new rule if the democrats
are going to continue to
debate stuff that happened in the 1970s
they have to dress in 70s clothing if
we're going to talk about busing
do it right even though nobody under 55
knows what you're talking about you may
as well be debating denture cream
but why bring it up at all does anyone
really think
today's helicopter parents would be into
bussing
little harper
90 minutes away to the poor side of town
but this is the new trick in democratic
politics dig up something your opponent
said decades ago that looks bad by
today's standards and pretend
that that's a mic drop evidence of your
awesome moral superiority
kirsten gillibrand tried to pull some of
that woke liberal time machine [ __ ]
on biden
calling out something he wrote 38 years
ago about women working outside the home
for more details visit the national
archives
it's on microfiche
[Music]
liberals are funny they believe in
evolution except when it comes to people
kamala harris was our attorney general
here in california in 2010 and i
contributed to her campaign
and i was disappointed when she opposed
legalizing marijuana
well now she's for it that's all that
matters
we don't need to beat her up about 2010.
that's called learning
we used to want that in a leader obama
was against gay marriage when he became
president as
was most of the country but then
i've been going through an evolution on
this issue and do you recall
who got him to evolve biden
humans evolve you could be against
gender inclusive bathrooms and then one
day
change your mind because you have to
take a wicked piss
people need to stop pretending that if
they were alive
back when they wouldn't have been the
same [ __ ] as everyone else
yes you would i know your parents told
you you're exceptional but not to the
point of seeing the future
you would have driven without seat belts
and drank when you were pregnant
and hit your kids and hit your
neighbor's kids they did that [ __ ]
yeah it's a remember the name because
woke site
is not 2020 and you don't have espcp
extra sensory politically correct
perception
if you were around in the 1980s you
would have worn those horrible colors
and the big shoulder pads you just would
have you're not
nostradamus and if you were around in
the 1780s
and you were rich and white you likely
would have had slaves
the first abolition society in america
was founded in 1775
and it had 24 members 24 people in the
whole country
thought slavery was wrong the year
before we declared
independence stop being surprised we
used to be dumber than we are
now the humans of tomorrow will be
horrified by us they won't believe we
used to sexualize people during
sex
millennials seem to think they came
along right as society met perfection
do you really think future generations
will look at what you're doing
the man buns and the
the giant stupid ear stretching earrings
and say
that was the moment civilization peaked
we can add nothing more
you're not morally better than your
grandparents you just came
later you're just the next upgrade
you're the iphone 11.
yeah it's funny nobody has trouble
grasping technological evolution
nobody writing a love note with a quill
ever said why can't i send a dick pic
nobody in 1975 asked why isn't my tv
flat
why is my 8-track not satellite radio
nobody's speaking into that kleenex box
that we had at first
was mad at it because it wasn't a
smartphone yet
things get obsolete because we grow and
improve
including us can we please stop pointing
out people breaking rules that didn't
exist yet
and just grandfather in the [ __ ] you
would have done
if you were alive then
i'm sorry joe biden had to get along
with segregationists
but when he first entered politics he
had to get along with aaron burr
you